Over the last few years, many people have changed careers
and reevaluated that work life balance,
what it looks like to them.
And now companies are responding.
Okay, this story blew my mind.
And this is now my favorite company.
Listen to this.
CNBC reports a tech company called Seven Rooms
is offering incredible incentives to their employees.
For new hires, they offer two fully paid weeks off
before they even start.
That's two free weeks at full pay to do whatever they want.
And that's not all.
All employees must take five consecutive days off
at least twice a year.
And longtime employees must double that
by taking 10 consecutive days off twice a year
Wow.
Thoughts?
(applause)
Are you hiring?
I'm not going anywhere,
but that tells people who wanna work at this company
right away, we value you.
We value you.
And as an employee, that is so important
and so different to hear.
This story really took my breath away.
And I just think Seven Rooms, let this work.
You could be the origin story to a new model
where we allow people a life and we reward them for it.
(applause)
And we feed their soul and interests.
And we give them things to look forward to
and plans to make
and take some of the financial burden out of it.
And I wonder if it will bring more focus and passion
in their job because they feel respected and incentivized.
Also, I just love this tone.
This is like, we value you.
From the get go.
I love it.
(applause)
I hope this is a success
and the first of many to follow.
(upbeat music)